hey everybody uh welcome to metaphysical
milkshake it is me rayne wilson
and i'm reza aslan hey um guess what i
was watching last night
what on on tv
um that's right
i'm gonna go with the gilmore girls
reboot
well
normally yes you know me well okay but
no no no no i was watching star trek
star trek my favorite show your favorite
show great love it one of my favorite
show um um was it was it um
no no no i know what you're gonna say
and it wasn't a uh episode of you as
harry mudd congratulations for the 10
000th time thank you thank you it really
was a dream come true it really was yeah
it was my dream come true
not just for you i by the way we
you promised me that you would get me to
be a red shirt on there in some way and
i'm holding you to that promise get up
to toronto and i'll get you i'll get you
guys a red shirt [ __ ] walk to toronto
just to be phasered in the first act
i will happily like the phaser you in
the first act welcome to metaphysical
milkshake the show where we go deep we
get weird and we search for the meaning
of life along the way presented by cast
media and soul pancake
we're both star trek fans and you know
the the the thing that i love about that
star trek world there's a lot of things
that i love about the star trek world
but the one thing that i love about is
the whole like you know there's no money
thing right they don't have any money
in the star trek universe yeah no no
i've totally noticed that too there's no
there's no money there's no credit cards
and bank accounts
um
you know it's a more evolved version of
human society and government and the
concept of money is obsolete
yeah uh in fact i actually have this
quote here from jean-luc
the greatest ladies and gentlemen the
greatest of all star trek cabinets he
says quote people are no longer obsessed
with the accumul maybe i'll do it in
isla and his voice people are no longer
obsessed with the accumulation of things
we've eliminated that is the worst
jean-luc picard accent i've ever heard i
should probably just read it in normal
just i think just read the quote yeah
okay people are no longer obsessed with
the accumulation of things we've
eliminated hunger want the need for
possessions we've grown out of our
infancy the challenge is to improve
yourself to enrich yourself make it so
make it so number one
i have to go number two
i think what's really interesting is
that um gene roddenberry knew something
that we're maybe starting to figure out
that the modern economic system of today
may be unsustainable and really needs to
move out of its infancy
exactly that's exactly what i was
thinking but i mean there's so much
there's so much messiness to it like i
get it okay so if you're on a ship then
you know you can just kind of replicate
a sandwich whenever you want to you
don't have to pay for the sandwich well
that's that's the key reza is technology
eliminated the need
for money because there's no more
scarcity because there's replicators
if everyone had a replicator and like i
would like a bowl of soup right now i
would like an earl grey tea
you know then you just press a button
and uh your needs are met
all right but what if you're not in what
if you're not in like um starfleet
do you still get uh you still get your
free soup that's the weird thing about
star trek is we never get to see
life on other planets with earthlings
like what do they do like are they
farmer they don't have to be a farmer
because you've got replicators what are
they doing they're
they're juggling they're bowling what is
life like with your average
not even a starfleet member just someone
who lives under the empire
exactly i mean like there still has to
be an economy right you still have to
like
have a commodity and and like produce
things people have just changed things
and
so like even in the the glorious you
know utopian
no money world of star trek it's still
a bit messy to figure out how
sort of the money of the future is going
to
to look like you know
i am sure there are still people in the
star trek future that are the haves and
the have-nots
yes
and so this got us thinking
about
a fundamental question a question that
like honestly we don't really ask
ourselves that much i know that the
first time that i asked this question
just the asking of it expanded my brain
to uncomfortable proportions which is
what the [ __ ] is money what is money
i mean like what is it it's a it's a
construct
it's definitely a construct yeah
one dollar gives you something at a
99-cent store
essentially
and we've all decided that you know get
some a mini pringles is one dollar and
this is the value of a mini pringles and
it's a one dollar and and this little
piece of paper which in and of itself
has no
inherent value just like we stamp a one
on it and we all just agree we all just
agree that this piece of paper is worth
one dollar it's like a a social
agreement right it only works if
everyone is willing to play
by the game and i guess the thing that
is truly fascinating to me is that
everyone is willing to play by the game
and no one questions it
no one questions it but yet it causes so
much pain chaos division and turmoil you
think about it
is money the root of all evil
yeah kinda yeah
a little bit
a little bit yeah so this brings up a
series of very fascinating questions and
good thing we have the iconoclastic
charles eisenstein here to help address
this very profound question yeah i mean
if you don't know charles eisenstein uh
he's a brilliant public speaker he's an
author he's
written on a bunch of different themes
small things like you know civilization
consciousness spirituality human
cultural revolutions the future of
humanity like you know little little
things the kind of stuff that i like to
think about some of his books include
sacred economics the ascent of humanity
and most recently climate a new story
and he's also a contributing editor to
the website reality sandwich
uh he went to yale studied philosophy
and mathematics lived in taiwan for
years became a translator speaks fluent
mandarin
and he was on oprah winfrey's super soul
sunday in 2017
which sounds like a big deal but so was
i
i mean wow
just saying i'm just saying like you
know okay congratulations charles you
did what i did
so charles eisenstein
thank you for joining us uh
okay
you're gonna have to deal with the fact
that ray and i are both like gigantic
fans charles heads do you the
eisensteinians
yeah well you know that happens all the
time so you know you're used to it
you're used to it uh yeah but what are
your fans called
we do need
yeah
that's good eisen stands eisen stands
eisen stands where eisen stands
why didn't we think of that by the way
i'm the original eisen stan okay i mean
rain joined the eisenstein i'm i'm late
yeah
very very late uh i i read this book in
2013.
uh see look i have like the original not
even the updated not even the updated
copy
uh
this book
absolutely just changed
the revised copy is so much better than
the original copy though all right okay
let's now that we've settled that i'm a
bigger uh eisenstein than reign is
uh sacred economic so
from the start
what you talk about is the
the kind of um
interaction or let's just say the the
relationship
between spirituality and money and we're
going to get into what is money where
did it come from that's the stuff that
like just it just drives me crazy i love
that conversation but before we get
there let's just kind of start at the
very beginning
how is money
spiritual
okay so i would not say that it's about
the relationship of spirituality and
money i would say more that it's about
the relationship of mythology and money
and by mythology i mean the basic
defining stories that run our
civilization
the way that we answer questions like
who am i
what is a human being
how does change happen in the world
where do we come from
where are we going what's real what's
important how do we live life like all
these basic questions
what's the nature of the universe and
and the thesis of the book is that money
is part and parcel of
the way that we answer those questions
it's part and parcel of the story of the
world that civilization holds
and
that this story is
in a state of
unraveling
the way that we have answered these
questions the way that we've understood
ourselves and understood the world isn't
working anymore
therefore the money system also
is failing us
leading to
a point of crisis
and
perhaps um a rebirth a different kind of
money system
that partakes in
a different mythology
and a different
uh
state of human beingness
that's
the broad outline yeah you write in the
book so it is hugely iconic and hugely
significant
that the one thing on the planet most
closely resembling the foregoing
conception of the divine
is money
it is an invisible immortal force that
surrounds and steers all things it's
omnipotent and limitless it's an
invisible hand
that it is said makes the world go round
yet money today is an abstraction at
most symbols on a piece of paper but
usually mere bits in a computer it
exists it exists in a realm far removed
from materiality
yeah
yeah i think that's in
the chapter where i discuss how
our ideas about what spirit is
come or or are
suggested by or informed by
the um
what money is
and and that the abstraction of money
actual things
uh mirrors the abstraction of spirit
from matter and that the healing would
be to bring spirit back into matter not
to ascend to some separate realm
of spirit but but to
embody spirit to see to understand that
sacredness is in the material world
not apart from it
and maybe that is the foundation of
restoring sacredness to money and
restoring humanity to ecology rather
than
uh
walking the path of of separation and
domination and conquest
is all part of the same movement
so i love that the title is sacred
economics and that you just talked about
you
brought a link between spirit and
sacredness i was
attempting and struggling with for a
while writing an essay about sacredness
because i had experienced some when i
went on a pilgrimage from my faith
community for the baha'i faith and i
experienced this really
deep profound sense of sacredness on
this pilgrimage essentially but i found
it almost impossible to define
what is sacred and i think you did a
hell of a job in your introduction but
before we get to sacred economics how do
you define sacred because you're you're
talking about sacredness being in the
real world not some kind of like airy
fairy abstraction yeah
yeah i mean i hesitate to define it
because it's trying to put it greater
within a lesser
something that's infinite inside of
concepts but
what i say in the book and and this gets
it something of it
is that for something to be sacred
well for one thing everything's sacred
either everything is sacred or nothing
is sacred
well is it is a mini mall with a with a
taco bell and a massage parlor and a uh
and a western union is that sacred and
it looks like crap and it's just thrown
up thoughtlessly in suburban omaha is
that sacred it's a lot harder to see it
as sacred
uh when when something is stripped of
its relationships and stripped of its
uniqueness
then it's also stripped of its
sacredness
so so the
um
and and
so basically what i'm saying is that
sacredness is a function of uniqueness
and relatedness
like if i if i
see you reign as
uh some
just a member of a dehumanized category
right then
like douchebag hollywood elite yeah dish
bag hollywood elite you know like that's
what he was trying to say um
a clueless white guy whatever it is okay
then
i am not seeing your absolute unique
individuality
and i have dehumanized you and
de-sacralized you and if i
if i am not aware of your relationships
i just take you as this
this separate discrete individual
out of context
i can't see
the way that you are in the world can't
see your embeddedness
so
you're just like a commodity which is
also standardized
shorn of its uniqueness and abstracted
extracted
from its relationships like you you
purchase something on on amazon and you
have no idea where it came from
what labor went into it what ecological
cost went into it like all of these
relationships that gave birth to it all
gone but it's so convenient
i press a button and the next morning
there's double a batteries at my
doorstep charles
yep
hey milkshakers nordvpn is a secure way
of preventing your personal information
from being spread around the web when
using wi-fi the line of protection is
wonderful it prevents spam viruses and
other unwanted privacy intruders listen
nowadays vpns are really important you
know like there's so much
security problems going on on the web
you know oftentimes when i need to like
log on to my university account i have
to do it through a vpn this is fantastic
and with nord i can access content from
over 59 countries just by changing my
virtual location with a single click
obviously we here live in the us but
with nordvpn we can be anywhere in the
world we can access content from any of
those regions when we're traveling folks
we're often using insecure restaurant or
airport wi-fi which are notorious for
stealing identity nordvpn is a great way
to protect you and prevent hackers from
stealing your information
you can even use nordvpn on up to six
devices laptop phone smart tv etc etc so
find out what we're talking about go to
nordvpn.com
milkshake or you can use code milkshake
to get up to 70 off your nord vpn plan
plus one additional month for free it's
also risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee folks we've all
made new year's resolutions i know that
for me i've decided that i want to be
more sustainable less wasteful
and now there's an easy way to do that
with eliminating single-use plastics
grove collaborative is here with
reusable swaps to make a lasting impact
at home for your family and the planet a
new year means a fresh start and a
chance to change the way you care for
the planet now's the perfect time to
make your home healthier happier and
more sustainable discover everything you
need for a sustainable home at grove
collaborative here's how it works grove
carries hundreds of products aimed at
replacing single-use plastics across
your home and your personal care routine
by 2025 grove itself is going to be a
hundred percent plastic free a new year
means new commitments to those we care
about family and the planet and if
you've been wanting to make more
sustainable choices for home care beauty
and more start today with grove
collaborative ready to make 2022 the
best year yet for your family in the
planet start a sustainable revolution at
home with grove collaborative shop over
150 brands that make a real impact
grove's concentrated cleaners and
refillable glass bottles are friendlier
to the planet and twice as effective as
the leading natural brand so you can
switch to sustainable products for every
room in your home from laundry care to
hand soaps and more grove has you
covered with safe formulas and
refillable packaging that never
compromise on performance we in the
aslan household we all uh swore that
starting in 2022 we would all be
as plastic free as possible we've given
up plastic straws we're using refillable
containers as often as possible but you
know until now i had no idea what to do
about all like my household cleaners and
you know disinfectants and things like
that so i am all in on this whole grove
collective thing so milkshakers join
over two million households already
shopping sustainably at grove go to
grove.com milkshake today to get a free
gift set worth up to fifty dollars with
your first order plus shipping is fast
and free get started right now at
grove.com
milkshake grove.com
milkshake
well all right so let's tell the story
of money as it has
been sort of crafted over the
you know millennia
a lot of the early parts of your book
just this fascinating history of like
how the concept of money um arose
you sort of talk about this notion that
everyone sort of
assumes which is that the earliest form
of money or the earliest form of sort of
commodity commodity exchange um was the
barter system right uh that like the
thing that you learned when you're in
like fourth grade that uh oh you know in
the old days what we used to do is say
um you've got a chicken well uh i've got
a necklace i'll give you this necklace
for that chicken and that's how you know
the the original economy human economy
arose but
that ain't true is it charles that's not
actually true at all tell us about the
earliest form of um of the economy
yeah um yeah the the barter that the
idea that money arose from as an
improvement on barter is
an economist's fiction it's total
fiction but but i swear to god if you
asked like 10 people on the street
10 of them would say yeah it began at
bartering
yeah actually the original economies
were always gift economies that's right
the gift economy tell us about the gift
economy well in a gift economy
so
if if i if if you're in my community
and
you are
you need something and i have
that thing
um
i give it to you
because i know well not because i know
but i know
and i've seen my entire lifetime that
gifts flow toward the need
therefore
i have no insecurity if i have nothing
that's okay because i know my community
is going to take care of me
and in fact
i know also that whoever is the most
generous and gives the most
is also
receives the most gratitude and is in
fact the most wealthy and the most
secure
another thing about gift culture
is that
is that a gift
relationship
creates a bond
like if you if you sell me something um
say like you sell me your uh
you know autographed photo
your hollywood autographed photo for
500
okay
and
and and like you give me that and i give
you 500
the transaction's over
but if you just give it to me
and i
without a return
now i kind of owe you one it's like if
you're if you go to your neighbor and
you borrow some sugar or some eggs or
something like that now your neighbor
feels at ease to come and borrow
something hey i need my lawnmower broke
down i need to borrow your lawnmower
like a relationship is created through
the giving of gifts imagine how strong a
community is
after years and decades and generations
of gifts circulating
so that was the original economy and
that works
fine
on a small scale when everybody's gifts
and needs are visible and you can have
informal
systems that that kind of govern who
gives what to whom under what
circumstances
but when when
larger civilizations emerged
these systems of of reciprocity and gift
uh
no longer
could function
to bridge
gifts and needs because there's just so
many of us like there's just so many of
us you know and you didn't know
everybody you know and the the
phenomenon of the stranger arose
and and the
like you don't trust a stranger you
don't know this person
uh so so
that was the that was the circumstances
under which
money arose first is credit actually not
as coinage not as cash
first as as a system of accounts
and then
eventually like in the
eighth century bc or something uh
coinage arose
anyway i know i'm not going to go too
much into this so just so essentially
what you're saying is
for millennia under this gift economy
essentially
the the purpose of
um these kinds of you know commodity
exchanges
were the purpose of it was primarily to
rearrange relationships in in the
community right so this notion that you
know i will give you goods now
in exchange for some goods in the future
that
i have more than i need and so i give it
to someone who needs something
um with the understanding that you know
eventually it's not it's not barter in
the sense that okay now you owe me a
chicken it's
more like when i need something i just
assume that you will be there for me the
way that i was there for you so it's
about like
building relationships building
communities
uh it it keeps you from hoarding
obviously right because what would be
the point in her why why would i keep 30
chickens if i don't need 30 chickens and
you need a chicken i'll just give you a
chicken and then one day you'll give me
a chicken back
it
keeps sort of social stratification from
forming right you don't have like
necessarily haves and have-nots because
we all just sort of rely
on each other it creates cooperation
um instead of you know competition where
it's like who's got the most
chickens it doesn't really matter
because we're all relying on each other
this is how we are
for millennia and then for really no
other reason
than uh because it's just convenient
because we're becoming larger and you
know our community is expanding so just
out of convenience
we come up with this sort of symbolic
gesture this thing right this like
thing that we're going to call money and
you're right we're not we don't we're
not even talking about anything even
standardized yet no coins no bills
nothing like that just this concept that
it almost becomes a
a stand-in for the exchange is that what
it is like in other words uh give me a
chicken here's this piece of paper
for that chicken and the and the paper
is representative or the there's no
paper but you know what i mean like the
shell whatever it's representative
of
um
the the exchange but it doesn't really
it doesn't the shell itself doesn't hold
any intrinsic value it's just
representative
of the fact that we have made this
exchange
am i saying that right am i did i do
that right yeah i mean i could you know
i could expand on some of the details
but but basically
the the key thing is that
the the the token of whatever kind it
could be a kaori kauri necklace you know
it could be a coin it could be
um an entry in a ledger
uh but whatever it is
there's a social agreement
about it
that renders it valuable
and this is even true uh with uh
you'd think that ancient coinage was all
gold and silver which has intrinsic
value right no it didn't that's right
yeah they they used all kinds of
base metals for coinage also and in fact
even when they are made of gold and
silver
the value is higher than the underlying
value of the metal
even if you're talking today about gold
like we talk about it has intrinsic
value
but does it really
outside of a social perception of value
is gold very useful to you
yeah i always wondered like why is
go oh gold is so i mean there's aspects
of gold like if you melt it you can
shape it in various forms and it doesn't
you know it doesn't corrupt
but i mean it's scary it's good for
electronics and stuff but if it's so
useful then why is two-thirds of all the
gold ever mined in history sitting in
vaults
yeah it's a social agreement that that
gold is worth something but this is
another fallacy about money and i think
for a lot of americans it's like well
the
dollar is meaningless once we've
abolished the gold standard we used to
link the dollar to a bar of gold we no
longer do that so uh it doesn't really
mean anything but it never really meant
anything it's always just a social
agreement isn't it
that's right
it's a social agreement
yeah yeah it needs it needs that sort of
that stamp on the coin otherwise it
doesn't it's just
you know a matter here's another thing
money is
okay another way to think about it money
is magic
imagine if you've you visited
you know some primitive tribe or you
thought they were primitive
and they are
drawing these symbols and manipulating
these symbols in the superstitious
belief
that the material world will change
thereby
well guess what
we do the same thing we manipulate
symbols called the called money that can
cause a nation to rise or fall cause
somebody to lose their home
if you have like the power of this magic
and you send them
the appropriate
like voodoo script
in the mail
you can devastate their lives
the script says account balance on top
of it
you can
use wielding the power of money
human beings are enslaved
sending all of their productive surplus
to the master of this
system of magical talismans
so it actually
is um
a very ancient
way of
managing and controlling other human
beings
a power that could be used in
destructive and productive ways
and that's why i also that's why i keep
going back to
what is the story
of money and what bigger story is it
part of right that's really the key
because
money doesn't exist in isolation
it's not like we have this bad idea
called whatever fiat currency or
fact fractional reserve currency and
then everything went downhill
it was actually an inevitable
development in a bigger context
a development that has maybe reached
reached its
finale now and we have to really ask
like
not only like what's the most clever
technical
idea for a more rational money system
but but beyond that
what kind of money would embody our
emerging values
our ecological values our social values
um and and even like
our our
changing consciousness our changing
understanding of what is
a human being and what is a human being
for
if you're like me as soon as you wake up
you're on the go i mean the next thing
you know it's lunch time you haven't
eaten anything no wonder you're always
hangry but what are your options so you
could run through a drive-through and
grab something that you know
is not good for you that's not a good
idea or you can try huel huel
human fuel provides all the carbs
proteins fats fiber and 27 essential
vitamins and minerals you need and
everything folks is plant-based
they have a wide range of convenient
on-the-go options for someone who wants
to eat healthy but doesn't have a ton of
time like me and reza because we're
always podcasting all day long i did not
eat lunch today that is a fact huel
powder comes in all the classic flavors
like vanilla chocolate salted caramel
and more mix it with water in the freeze
shaker you'll get with your first order
and you're good to go
there's also a pre-mixed ready-to-drink
option to help you save even more time
and if you want even more protein or
less carbs there's a naturally
gluten-free option
called huel black edition it's the
ultimate human fuel and huels new hot
and savory meals are fantastic they've
got mac and cheese mexican chili thai
green curry and a few others that you
just gotta try to believe and each one
of them takes less than five minutes to
make fuel is proof that fast food can be
good food i love it and you will too and
right now you can save fifteen dollars
on your first order plus get free
shipping a shaker and a free t-shirt oh
my god free t-shirt thank you go to
huel.com
milkshake that's huel.com
milkshake to save 15
on your first order plus free shipping a
shaker and a t-shirt
hewl.com
milkshake
well so another another big uh
psychological effect i guess uh is greed
right this notion of if this if this
social construct this symbol
that we have
implanted you know uh an agreed valued
uh upon has
this inherent value uh uh in and of
itself it's if it's more than just a a
means to exchange for services or goods
but it's a thing
that in and of itself is valuable
well then just gimme gimme gimme right i
just want fresh as much of this thing
as possible but you have something
really mind-blowing that you talk about
when you talk about greed
because we all say like you know oh
you know money makes someone greedy and
you're saying no no money doesn't
necessarily make you greedy
it's the perception that that money
provides this perception of scarcity
and it's the perception of scarcity that
makes us greedy like if we think that
there aren't enough of something
then psychologically speaking we try to
get as much of that as possible right
that's why like every once in a while
there's like a run on toilet paper or
like chicken wings you know there's
going to be there's going to be a you
know not enough chicken wings for the
super bowl i gotta get me as many
chicken wings as possible
someone has to convince you
that money is scarce
so that
you want more uh i totally remember
during the early days of covid when this
when the food was flying off the shelves
i had this exact same reaction just
personally just like we have a a
housekeeper cleaning woman mara saul
who's amazing um and she's worked with
our family for a long time she's super
cool and she was like going to the store
and i was like
um i i got scared you know i was reading
these reports i'm like
we need uh noodles or pasta something
that keeps a long time cans of soup or
beans like any beans and then she called
from like the grocery store she's like
there's nothing on the shelf
except there is some beans
what kind of beans this is what happens
you put the face time on the beans and
it was like
it was like these weird navy beans from
like poland and i'm not kidding it was
like
japanese black beans but they don't look
like any black beans you've ever seen
before and they were super expensive by
the way it's like organic
4.50 cents for a bag of little japanese
mung beans and i was like buy them buy
them beans
and guess what guess where they are
they're in your
pantry
we never made we never cooked the beans
i just i totally bought into the
scarcity mindset yeah and well or just
like when you go to the when you went to
the grocery store and they were like
one toilet paper for per family
right that's what that's all you can
have is one
it's all this perception of scarcity i
don't think i've never heard anyone talk
about
the the issue of greed in these terms so
so help us understand exactly what you
mean to this idea that money has to
convince you of this lie and there's a
lot of that's not okay i'm sorry wait no
yeah that's not quite it no no hey
charles let me explain what you think
all right buddy okay
okay good good yeah okay so do it the
right way
right so it
sure looks like greed is the big problem
in our society and it sure makes a
convenient target you know to blame
greedy people
for
the
inequality and the excess and all that
but i ask
i like to ask
because you know i kind of tend to think
people are good you know so i ask
well what makes somebody greedy under
what circumstances does it make sense
and it is under circumstances of
scarcity or at least the perception of
scarcity
if you are
fully abundant and all your needs are
taken care of and you have
no reasonable
doubt that they will continue to be
taken care of then why would you be
greedy if you live in a strong gift
culture
where
i quoted one indigenous man in the in
the book
who was asked by an anthropologist
you know you're a good hunter you make a
big kill you know why don't you smoke
the meat and store the meat um so you'll
have it for months and months in case
there's no game you don't do that
instead you just hold a feast and it's
all gone in one day
and he and the 100 gatherer he said no
you don't understand i i do store meat i
store meat in the belly of my brother oh
that's awesome
because he knows that after he holds a
feast like that i mean he's going to be
invited to everybody else's feast too
so
no greed like no hoarding you know
so we don't live in that kind of
situation we live in a situation where
there is no community to depend on
and our security we are only as secure
as the security of our money generally
speaking so
that
um experience of scarcity which which
barrages us from every direction i mean
we have a society where where everything
is scarce
quiet is scarce
beauty is scarce
connection intimacy is for many people
scarce people are lonely
time
time is scarce time is definitely scarce
you want to find leisurely people you
have to go to the third world
all of our labor saving devices have
somehow made us busier and busier and
maybe as we try to keep pace
with the pace of technology and money is
scarce
also artificially scarce the story is
that
there's a village okay and everybody is
using chickens for money so when every
time they want to buy something they
carry a couple chickens under their arm
you know and it's really
inconvenient
so one day
a stranger comes to town with a with you
know
a white hat and fancy shoes
and he says
i have a much better solution instead of
using chickens here i cut out some
leather leather rounds some little round
pieces of leather use these instead each
of these represents one chicken and i'll
give them to you to use
i'll give everybody in town
10 rounds to use
uh
the only stipulation though
is that
after one year every that you have to
give me 11 rounds
back well you'll let you use them for a
year they're alone an interesting loan
so
and they say
well if we're each getting 10 rounds
then how are we going to give you 11
back and he says oh you'll see you'll
see
so they take the gift
and they start using the rounds and it
is very convenient
but because
each one of them has to give 11 back
they are plunged into competition with
each other
in into competition for not enough
rounds
and whereas before they were generous
and they shared you know and they looked
out for each other now everybody's in
competition with each other and at the
end of the year
most of the people can pay him his 11
rounds back except for those who have
gone bankrupt
that's basically
um it's an illustration of how
money is lent into existence
and what i added to this story is in
fact after a
year they can pay him back because by
that time he's lent more rounds
into existence and that's how our
financial system works and that's why
growth is necessary for it to function
and when the economy stops growing then
you have horrible problems rising
inequality unemployment uh bankruptcy
and so forth
the economy has to grow because more
money has to continually be lent into
existence for people and businesses to
have the wherewithal to repay the
principal and interest on previous
lending
so it just has to grow and grow and grow
and for it to grow it's lent into
existence
to two people who will pay it back
who will be able to create new goods and
services who will be able to replace
neighborly home building with insurance
to replace
uh children playing outside with daycare
to replace
handmade clothes with the fashion
industry and so forth these are all
market expanding business
ventures
with uh these are capital investments
that bring a return so we get more and
more and more of these a relentless
pressure
uh to expand forever and ever until
all of nature and all of culture has
been monetized so you have to come up
with new ways to use chickens
necessarily the only way that you're
going to come up with that extra piece
of leather is essentially to take it
from someone else so someone is going to
lose in that in that case you know if
there's 10 of you nine of you will do
just fine nine of you will will return
11 but one of you now has nothing
and it's like that is the foundation of
our entire financial
system but it's but i don't know that i
even agree with that reza i think it's
like someone is gonna end up with the 13
rounds and someone's only gonna have
four and then that person who had 13
then the next year they've turned that
into 28 rounds and people have less than
then they're borrowing from him and he's
like i'll pay you back but you've got to
pay me at 12.
i'll give you 10 but you got to pay me
12 back and he increases the interest
rates and so that's how we have this
kind of like polarization
of the haves and the have-nots it's like
money money can work only if we create
the illusion of scarcity
it's the scarcity
that then leads you know essentially to
to greed and then the greed
kind of necessitates debt
and debt is the key
to the entire system like it work speak
works uh because of debt so
so what's the answer where do we go how
take us bring it bring us bring this on
home uh
well
and let me give a suggestion
is perhaps where we're going and i'm
going to bring this back to science
fiction is perhaps where we're going
trekonomics
because think about
star trek what happens in star trek i'm
a big trekkie trekker geek
uh so is reza are we talking about so we
have replicators you can have a bowl of
soup you can have earl grey tea then
scarcity is eliminated and there is
simply no need for money and so
humanity's purpose then is to live in
peace and harmony and explore the
universe is that a potential path for us
going forward
yeah okay
so
scarcity already has been eliminated
fundamentally
despite the fact that a huge proportion
of the world's population lives in dire
poverty
the reason that they are in poverty is
not because there isn't enough
it's because it's not distributed
equitably
half the world wastes enough food to
feed the other half several times over
so
the the problem is artificial scarcity
we are fundamentally in a very abundant
world
100 gatherers lived abundantly they
spent an average of 20 hours a week on
subsistence
less than people spend today
the problem though is that our
system is geared around scarcity and it
generates scarcity so the most obvious
example like we don't have replicators
like star star trek does yet or i don't
know if we ever will but we do have a
huge sector of the economy a huge
category of goods that are
of that
nature which is digital goods
it does not cost
cost
anymore like to make the first copy of a
movie
costs a lot of money
to make the second copy costs nothing
to make the third copy cost nothing
there's no reason that for people to pay
for movies
because the natural price point of
something that has a marginal cost of
production of zero
is
zero so in order for
movies to remain a business they have to
create artificial scarcity
you have to create pay walls you have to
create digital rights management
so
this
is just like the most glaring example of
artificial scarcity that is totally
unnecessary and to make it more personal
it's like okay we could change the
system right but you can also
change your individual
actions
and one way that i've done this and
explored and i could you know help
others to move into is to implement gift
economics for digital goods
where for example i make an online
course or something like that
and
and i'm like
you decide what to pay for it could be
zero but i'm not gonna put it behind a
paywall
because like what if you know you're
struggling to pay the groceries you know
like i don't want you to pay then
and if you're making a seven figure
income
i would gratefully accept
10 times more than you would ordinarily
pay for an online course
so i i use this business model which
is based on a different view of human
nature conventional economics as human
beings maximize rational self-interest
and the new story says human beings
desire to give
and they respond to generosity with
gratitude which births generosity in
turn
and guess what the proof is in the
pudding my business model works
and it works for other people too it's
there's
you know some
radiohead did it with their album
radiohead yeah right
um open source software works like that
in some cases like you can do it
um
and there's some you know hurdles to get
over but
it's totally feasible how do we expand
that to sort of other aspects of economy
how do we insert this concept of a of a
sacred relationship into
the way that we interact with you know
money
uh you know in in sort of other
non-digital realms like going to the
store or food or property or things like
that you know like
what what does it require in in our
psychological
workings what kind of shift is necessary
for us to start thinking about money in
a different way
yeah i mean
one of the shifts necessary is to
um create money in a different way to
have it
represent a different system of
agreements that no longer compels
more competition and more scarcity than
it would be already i'm not saying that
there's no such thing as scarcity and
that we could abolish competition but we
have a system that generates
more and more and more of it
mathematically
we could change those mathematics by
having a different system of money
creation
and
the other thing is
to
bring ourselves back into
more
robust multi-dimensional relationships
with each other especially locally
especially in community to to
reclaim
not all but some
of those parts of life
that have been
um exported onto the money world
to start doing things for each other
with our own hands and and for each
other again to you know gather together
to sing together again to build together
again to cook food for each other to
grow food for each other to do more
things locally
by doing that we reclaim to share more
you know the average
lawnmower is used
you know an hour a week
why does every single garage need one
um would we be poorer if we shared our
lawnmowers no we'd be richer actually
you have more occasion to meet the
neighbors
you know so so this is
partly it's a shift in system and partly
it's a shift in
our our attitudes
and and i think you know maybe it takes
a crisis maybe it takes a breakdown
in the current system
like when there's a natural disaster or
something and people come together
because
they have to
and they then they remember like some
people say that was the
best week of my life when
after the hurricane hit after the
blackout happened
one of the things you talk about in your
book is this concept that capitalism is
based on infinite growth with finite
resources it's unsustainable yeah and
you talk at great length about how
you know these systems may have worked
in the past
and they got us to a certain point but
now they're breaking down and they
cannot work going forward
so
um
maybe it does maybe we do need just uh
the the big crash
uh to kind of force our hand to
completely rethink our relationship to
money and economics i think that's the
the strongest argument that you make in
the book is that
no matter what you think of you know my
solution to this the way that we should
rethink money in the way that we should
rethink um scarcity
the alternative is
a collapse like i mean it it's everyone
who thinks about this for more than a
few minutes recognizes how unsustainable
it is and yes i know we we talk about
like the great economic collapse of you
know the 20s or the huge economic
collapse of 2008 or we're now moving
towards another economic collapse
and we don't sort of put two and two
together and realize well maybe there's
a fundamental flaw in the system if we
keep having these economic collapses
right
um so it's like what's the alternative
you know i mean
it may seem like a a big thing
to ask of of you know human civilization
to
rethink capitalism as we know it but you
know the alternative is that we just
keep
having these you know uh
collapses of the global economy until
finally there's no way to build up again
each of these
crisis points each of these collapses it
doesn't save us from ourselves but it
provides us with a moment of choice
either we double down
on the old story we go even more into
debt more into inequality or we say
enough
and we build a new system based on
ecological values based on compassion
based on abundance
yeah that's the choice that comes again
and again all right charles uh it is now
time for what we call our lightning
round so uh what we're just gonna do is
we're gonna just kind of throw
sort of random big questions at you and
you just answer you know the first thing
that that comes to your mind all right
you ready you ready for this good all
right here we go
uh
if you were stranded on an island what
three items would you take with you
uh a knife
um
a hat and
um
a lighter
i will sell you those three items uh
i'll give you a hat for 19.99 and a
lighter for 3.99 and a knife for 39.99
uh available at
metaphysicalmilkshake.com
um
what is something that no one or very
few people know about you
we've stumped you
yeah i'm like so so freaking public you
know
um
and tend to overshare even
um
something that few people would know
about you
um just
um
but i was uh a stay-at-home dad for
for several years
oh nice that's great
uh what book changed your life
order out of chaos by
frigid guy and stingers
wow
okay
mark that one down
what do you think happens to us after we
die
um
we
have
a profound
experience
okay
i like that
uh if you had a time machine
where and when would you go
i would go to
the year 3000
future
in the year 3000
uh what recharges your soul going for
walks with no timeline
you have kids so there's always a
timeline
yeah without
without kids or timeline without a
schedule you know without like
yeah yeah nowhere to be
um what's one thing about yourself that
you would like to change
you know it's like in a process of
change i almost don't want to jinx it
by saying i still like to change it when
it actually is already changing and
maybe changed but
let's say
um
in recent years i've been
changing my habit of approval seeking
[Music]
great good one good one that's a good
one what gives you hope for humanity
the overwhelming beauty that i
find when i really look closely
and deeply into somebody's eyes
like mine
if i did
yeah it's like wow like
beauty when you such a divine being
exists how could i be hopeless you know
i'd like to end there uh and then
finally uh what is your life's big
question
why
you you and my six-year-old same
question
why
that's good if you can line up your
life's big question with that of a
six-year-old i think you're on to
something i agree i agree
that's beautiful
uh charles eisenstein thank you so much
uh as you know we are eisen stans
and even more so after this incredible
discussion you've given us so much to
think about and really thank you
giving so generously your gift
of your time your wisdom your knowledge
uh thank you it was fun i enjoyed it as
well all right take care charles thank
you thanks
wow that was mind-blowing man i just
love his writing so much it is so
specific
but yet so all-encompassing so universal
it's yes it's about economics and making
them sacred and kind of reimagining our
our
relationship with money and economies
but it's about so much more it's about
humanity it's about humanity evolving to
a next level
um it's just beautiful and this whole
idea of this gift economy has really
inspired me and
you know
um
i would like to gift you something i'd
like to give you know what i'd like to
give gift you any number of things
from right here from what you can see on
camera from my desk
i have um
uh
uh
uh a little mini sword from morocco oh
that's made out of silver i would like
to give this to you i have
um
i have a tape dispenser that's nice it's
not as nice very sword obviously but
okay i'll give it all to you i mean i
think i was this is my father's pocket
knife right here that he had he bought
in the 70s he passed away this year i
would like to give you
my father's pocket knife i have so much
more i want to give you i'm looking
around what do you have what do you have
for me well i'll be honest i was sort of
hoping that you were going to say you
were going to gift me you know some of
your office uh profits but but okay uh
oh yeah so yeah how about um
uh what do i what do i have here i have
a i have actually
a
a little hand massager that i think
okay i think you know i feel like are
you [ __ ] kidding me
i'm talking about my father's pocket
knife i'm talking about a moroccan sword
and you're talking about hand massager
are you kidding me that's not how the
gift economy works i'm giving you this
stuff so you gift me something awesome
and precious too you missed the entire
point what am i gonna get out of this
what am i going to get out of this
interaction
ruler
trevor wolfe come and join us
welcome to the show glad to be here
where are you calling from i'm calling
from morrison colorado near denver
colorado ah near denver
are you a broncos fan i am a broncos fan
i'm wearing a peyton manning t-shirt
right now oh the days of peyton manning
do you do oh
uh trevor you have a que you have a
question about uh christianity and
forgiveness i am dying to find out what
this is what this is all about yes me
too i would love to hear everyone's
perspective yeah so i just come from a
christian viewpoint and i'm just wanting
to know are we able
to know if we can be forgiven of our
sins and who is able to forgive us of
our sins we actually we actually did
this very interesting um
podcast episode i think it ran already
i'm not sure
um about the idea of forgiveness
and one of the things that we thought
what we were talking about forgiveness
which is so funny is that
it's so often a transactional
thing
do you know what i mean
like so so often when we when we forgive
someone it's like in order to receive
something maybe even not from them like
in order to receive something from the
world or in order to receive
you know
something about just feeling better or
whatever the case may be
and i was thinking about this because
i've read the bible a few times that
might come as a shock but i have read
the bible a few times and one thing that
i've always noticed about the world
write a book about it
one thing that i've always noticed about
the way the new testament especially
talks about forgiveness is that it it
does have this
transactional quality to it right like
matthew 6 14 if you forgive other people
when they sin against you your heavenly
father will also forgive you and
we can talk about like the whatever like
the spiritual significance is very being
pro quo oh god but yeah do you know what
i'm you know what i'm saying rain
do you do do you feel the kind of
transactional nature yeah but but i
think i think you know jesus audiences
was you know for the most part like
fisher people and laborers and you kind
of
you have to teach in a certain way so um
but i think you know forgiveness is a is
a large question obviously trevor's
coming from a specifically christian
background but
i think that there is something really
beautiful in the act of forgiveness
um we have to learn how to forgive
ourselves right um
and there is a certain as a theist and
an a practicing religious person i know
mind-blowing
this act of contrition of uh asking for
to be absolved
of the wrongs whenever one has done with
our creator
is very powerful and very humbling and
we live in a world where
humility is not prized as you notice we
don't we don't elect the most humble
person as the president right we we
have the most you know kind of most loud
and an opinionated person as president
not necessarily the most humble so there
is a humility in that and
and then we need to ask occasionally a
forgiveness from one another i i
recently had a
a conflict with a very good friend of
mine who i felt like really hurt me and
um
uh and just wronged me in a number of
ways and he's a dear dear old friend and
we had a series of conversations it
wasn't you oh thank god classic
narcissist it's not about you
and
um
now please forgive me for saying that
president that was a little mean
i was a little mean i forgive you as the
lord has forgiven me thank you the lord
will now as you've forgiven me the lord
will now forgive you of being a boob
but uh it was an interesting thing
because he apologized to a certain
extent i kind of wished he had taken
further responsibility but at the at the
end of the day i was like listen this
guy's been a really good friend of me
i've known him a long time and i'm going
to choose to forgive i'm going to like
take this active step
in my heart i'm going to say i forgive
you for this
and
uh
it's proactive
and immediately i felt better and i have
had a relief on my shoulders
and you know we're the friendship is
healed and we text and we joke and we
work together and have a great time and
um
so i think that there is um you know i
think there's a lot to that no as far as
like
you know if you're talking from the
christian perspective about hell you
know i don't buy it i don't i don't buy
that god would create seven billion
people put them on a planet have half of
them not even hear about jesus in order
that he has this
plan to cast half of them into eternal
damnation if they don't ask
for forgiveness um or accept any certain
religious figure as their as their lord
and savior but
that's a whole other discussion but it's
a related discussion but i think the the
at its core the idea of forgiveness has
a lot of different levels and layers to
it and i know that i have been
at times in my life in prayer and in
meditation asking for forgiveness from a
power greater than myself and there is
it is a beautiful act and a humbling act
of contrition that is very emotional and
um
has
made my life
richer
trevor what do you think yeah but i
think that one thing i really think with
uh forgiveness it's on
for for me to forgive someone it's all
on my part the other person
they they don't have to accept my
forgiveness and we don't have to
reconcile we don't have to get along
anymore we don't have to like each other
anymore but forgiveness is all for me
it's really freeing to forgive people
and i think of what jesus did for us on
the process he forgave everyone
including me who this sinner who's done
things i've al all my good works are
like dirty filthy rags as i see in
isaiah 64. um what i also
see is
that forgiveness can be hard forgiving
other people but it wasn't easy for
jesus to be on the cross and be able to
take my position um one thing you're
talking about reconciliation one of my
favorite passages is
second corinthians 5 verse 21 for our
sake he made him to be sin who knew no
sin so that in him we might become the
righteousness righteousness of god we
give
god our sin and what jesus gives us is
eternal life so it is an exchange and i
think that is one of the
best biggest gifts that we can ever get
i take uh
jesus's words very literally and you
know he said he was asked should i
forgive my brother seven times and he
said no you should forgive him 77 times
so i will always
forgive you 77 times but that's 78th
time
reign forget it that 78th time
it's over trevor someone mentioned that
you knew someone that i knew yes i
actually know several people you know
but uh i know steve sarawicz oh nice
okay great yes yeah i met him in toronto
at the parliament of world religion oh
yeah he's a wonderful dude baha'i friend
of mine and a
great great human being and
philanthropist that's great awesome yep
i do a rui class with him every
wednesday oh fabulous oh great yeah all
right well give him my best please and
trevor thanks so much for sharing your
perspective and calling into the show
thanks so much for tuning in everyone
thanks for uh charles eisenstein for all
of his incredible wisdom about sacred
economics that's right uh diving in to
the milkshake of the metaphysical do you
guys want more of life's big questions
find us on social media at raza aslan
rain wilson at metaphysical milkshake on
all the socials
let us know what you thought is a sacred
economy possible
um give us your life's biggest questions
we just might explore them on a future
episode and you know by the way it's
free like you don't have to pay for this
podcast there may be some ads
there maybe some ads
just like you know do what i do is fast
forward through the ads no don't do that
don't do that pay attention listen to
our ads
we are gifting you this conversation
and in return listen to our sponsors
that's right and
and buy stuff from them and uh you know
what else is free it's free to follow
rate and review metaphysical milkshake
on the apple podcast or wherever you
transition to your podcasts well done
you can also subscribe to the
metaphysical
milkshake youtube channel and
which is free
and hit that skip ad after the five
seconds skip ad skip ads get bad
uh and you can watch our full episodes
of our conversations every week
thanks again to charles eisenstein
mind blowing we'll see you next week
thank you
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubel
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
you're like you're one of those people
who has like a lot of devoted fans
online you're like if if jordan peterson
were not a misogynist prick that would
that's kind of you like i feel like
that's so inappropriate charles eisen
said he might be good friends with
jordan peterson
maybe it's true could possibly probably
not though
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you